If you want to hear about the undiscovered
rooms of the Nerve Gas House that we never
see in the movie, then stick around to the
end of this video.
[INTRO]
“Greetings. And welcome...”
...to Things You Missed.
I love how cheerfully he says greetings.
Gets me every time.
Director James Wan would step away from the
Saw franchise after the first film, and open
the door…
“SOMEBODY OPEN THE ****ING DOOR!”
...for a new face to take the reins on the
series, so Saw II would be directed by Darren
Lynn Bousman.
Bousman would head up the next three movies,
and establish most of what we think of when
we think of Saw today.
I’d consider the Saw saga to be more his
product than any other director, and he would
return to direct the 9th installment, Spiral.
With a new director came some new Things You
Missed, so grab your magnifying glass, and
let’s get into them.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
The movie opens the same way that the first
did: with a light.
We see a bare light bulb come in and out of
focus and it suddenly shines very bright.
In the first Saw, I said that the light represented
Jigsaw trying to enlighten his test subjects
and make them see the error of their ways.
That concept took more of a center stage in
Saw II, making this an appropriate opening.
Some of John’s trap designs throughout the
Saw series took ancient torture devices and enhanced
them with industrial advances.
One example is the first trap of the movie,
the Venus Fly Trap, which drew inspiration
from the medieval contraption, The Iron Maiden,
only this was more like a cute little iron
maiden for your face.
When the victim watches his tape, the assistant
seen on screen has a bit of a limp, there’s
a slight hobble to his step.
If you’ve seen the twist at the end of Saw
7, you now know why.
If you’re about to correct me and say, “It’s
called Saw 3D or Saw: The Final Chapter,”
save you breath, I prefer to call it Saw 7.
*hip-hop music*
Soon after we meet Eric Matthews, who is going
to pick up his son Daniel who’d been caught
shoplifting at an electronics store.
During this scene, the camera cuts away to
a shot of a security camera, which shows us
the reason that Daniel is so familiar with
security technology later on…
“Those types of cameras don’t have sound.”
And more importantly, establish one of the
main concepts of Jigsaw’s next game.
Part of what makes the twist work is the fact
that we, as the audience, believe that what
we are seeing on these monitors is a live
feed.
On a side note, this is one of the only movies
to establish a relationship we care about,
the father son dynamic between Eric and Daniel,
before they both get tangled up with Jigsaw,
and it goes a long way to help make this the
most powerful entry in the series on an emotional
level.
Eric is called in to see the Jigsaw crime
scene that we saw in the opening because the
killer has called out Detective Matthews…
or rather, Detective Mathews.
As brilliant as Jigsaw may have been, it looks
like he still struggles with spelling.
We know that double-Ts is the correct spelling,
because that’s how the names appear in the
end credits.
When Eric is back at the police station, many
notices and wanted posters cover the walls,
while the shelves are filled with binders
and boxes of evidence files.
One of these boxes is for a case about a victim
named Greg Copeland, a reference to the co-producer
of Bousman’s initial three Saw films, who
also served as a production manager and second
unit director.
Another box in that room lists a victim named
Charlie Taylor, who was the film’s weapons
wrangler.
After Matthews has the realization about the
location of Jigsaw’s hideout, the SWAT team
makes an entrance strategy on the whiteboard,
which involved several smaller teams of men.
The first team consisted of Black, Faulkner,
Wisman and Brady, which corresponded to electrician
Craig Black, key grip Chris Faulkner (or possibly
his brother Tyler), first assistant editor
Ron Wisman Jr. and art director Michele Brady.
OK, enough of that boring stuff, you know
****’s about to go down when Jigsaw puts
away his cereal.
The main game of Saw II is the Nerve Gas House,
where 8 criminals must solve puzzles to win
the antidotes to the poison being pumped in
through the ventilation system.
From what I’ve heard, the original scripts
of the film have detailed the specific traps set for
each character, but the final cut only shows
the location of 5 antidotes: the one
in the safe in the room they start off in,
the two in the furnace trap, the one in
the needle pit, and the one in the razor box.
Of those five, only one game was played by
the test subject it was intended for, which
was Obi, who was challenged to go into the
furnace trap.
According to the director’s commentary,
the razor box trap was intended for Gus,
who doesn't make it that far because he
falls victim to the Magnum Eyehole very early
on.
Normally I wouldn’t consider the information in the commentary track canon,
so I wouldn’t include something
like that in my Things You Missed, but we
do see that Gus is a businessman, and the
trap seems to have been created to punish
greed.
It’s not hard to imagine that Gus was chosen
by Jigsaw because of corporate greed.
We more or less find out why Addison was chosen
in Saw 4, and the razor box trap doesn’t
seem to fit the bill for prostitution.
So who were the other antidotes supposed to
go to?
In my headcanon, the second needle in Obi’s
trap would have gone to Daniel, since he’s
just a kid, and you know all the usual cliches
about him having his whole life ahead of him
and stuff.
I’m not saying that the other prisoners
would have let that happen, but I think that’s
how Jigsaw drew up the game.
The only other one we know for a fact is the
needle pit trap, which was intended for Xavier,
but he ends up throwing Amanda into the pit
to do his task for him.
Speaking of which, I think we can subtract
one, because it seems pretty clear that because
Amanda was in on the game, she had already
been treated.
This is supported by the fact that she never
runs out of breath or spits up blood as the
others do.
So that leaves Laura, Addison and Jonas.
I think that the antidote in the safe would
have been for Jonas, because he seems most
interested in solving the riddle that Jigsaw left
for them on the tape, so it’s likely that
John knew he liked puzzles, and that would
essentially become his task.
So that just leaves Addison and Laura.
There are plenty of locked rooms in the corridors
that we never see the inside of, and some
of them seem to just open on their own once
a certain amount of time had elapsed, but
neither of these characters lived long enough
to make it to their tests.
While we don’t see the inside of their rooms
in the movie, we can learn about the traps
that may have been inside them if we take
a closer look at the design sketches pinned
up all over Jigsaw’s workshop.
John Kramer’s headquarters at the Wilson
Steel Plant seemed to be his go-to spot for
research and development.
Taking a look around, the place is covered
with blueprints, design sketches and prototypes
for traps, which were tested on the mannequins
scattered around the facility, which were
probably brought over from his previous workshop
at Stygian Street, whose location had been
compromised by Detective Tapp in 2004.
The designs include previous traps, like the
original reverse bear trap, which we saw Amanda
tested on during the first movie, or the Venus
Fly Trap from the opening of this movie.
Many of the sketches represent the traps seen
at the Nerve Gas House, like the Razor Box
and The Magnum Eyehole.
If those are present, chances are we can also
see the two unseen traps from the Nerve Gas
House, the ones intended for Laura and Addison.
There are a number of traps that can be seen
in the workshop that don’t correspond to
any trap that’s used during the series,
like this one, which appears to be some kind
of skull cage, possibly with the intention
of impaling the victim’s head.
Another variation on the idea shows up later,
and looks to introduce an electric shock component
to the design.
Another design shows us some kind of gas mask
with a switch on the front.
When we see more concept sketches later, one
of them is labeled as The Toxin Table, though
it is not known if that is meant to be used
in conjunction with the gas mask.
This thing may or may not be the Toxin Table.
Assuming the gas mask and Toxin Table do go
together though, I’d guess that is the trap
for Addison, I can see there being some kind
of analogy being made with toxins being compared
to disease and the gas mask being compared
to protection as it pertains to the corner
girl lifestyle.
We don’t ever find out why Laura is tested
by Jigsaw, but she would have the last trap
by default, be it the electric skull cage
thing, or one of these other prototypes.
Another possibility is this football helmet
one, but there isn’t any evidence of John
getting started with any preliminary designs
on that.
There are other trap designs that I think
may be very early versions of some of the
other devices John would use later in his
career.
Would you call serial killing a career?
I mean I guess in his case it’s more of a retirement
plan.
“Hello investment firms…
I see you’ve fraudulently mishandled funds
for my… *laughter* for my 401K.
I can’t do this.”
But yeah, right here I noticed a trap that
looks to be some kind of spinal cord device,
which reminded me of the Spine Cutter trap
that Art Blank had to wear in Saw 4.
There was also this mannequin with a series
of tubes running from the head, and I have
to wonder if that would be related to the
Oxygen Crusher that eventually appeared in
Saw 6.
Outside of what we actually see in John’s
workshop, there is also a moment that I believe
inspired future traps in the series.
When John is talking to Detective Matthews,
he describes the moment his mission truly
began, when he tried to take himself out Bill Murray
Groundhog Day style and the way he describes
what he felt is an important step in how he
came to believe that his traps would cause
people to appreciate life.
Roll it.
Off the side of a cliff.
"To my amazement, I was alive...
...and I was determined to spend the rest of my days...
...testing the fabric of human nature."
The obvious trap idea to come out of this
would be the Horsepower Trap from Saw 7, where
one of the victims experiences a
car crash from the same perspective John would
have had when he threw his vehicle into autopilot
when there was no autopilot cause it was the
mid-90s.
But after the crash John can be seen pulling
these stakes out of his body, and I think
that's what gave him the idea for the Spike Trap,
which he would use in Saw Si…-- four?
Guys, I am so good at reading Roman numerals…
...as this seems to be the part of the experience
that really made him feel alive.
But enough about the traps, let’s talk about
the game.
“This whole house is a trap.”
Touche.
At the very beginning Amanda is asleep, face
down on the floor like she’s some kind of
Taking Back Sunday lyric.
(Though if anyone’s a lyriq in this movie,
it’s Rigg.)
Amanda, who would be the facilitator of the
game at The Nerve Gas House, starts off in
the exact same position that John Kramer did
when he facilitated The Bathroom Game a year
prior.
Eric’s son Daniel is wearing some band merch
for a group called Wrath of the Gods.
Those of you who saw my Things You Missed
episode on the first Saw may remember a character
named Scott Tibbs, who was Adam’s childhood
best friend, who also went on to make his
own documentary about Jigsaw.
Scott’s band in that documentary is none
other than Wrath of the Gods.
“Scott Tibbs, lead guitar, founder of Wrath
of the Gods.”
Last week I said that The Scott Tibbs Documentary
was non-canon, but after watching it again,
there isn’t really anything that contradicts
the movies… so I’m not sure why Saw fans
consider it to be non-canon.
I think it’s just because they don’t like
it.
But outside of Daniel’s Wrath of the Gods
shirt being a reference to Scott Tibbs, it
also represents the cult of Jigsaw, who would
come to see himself as a God, so you could
say he brought his wrath down upon his many
victims.
This wrath would not extend to Daniel himself
though, and Jigsaw gives a couple of little
clues towards the boy being safe.
Or at least… being in a safe.
"Tell me where he is."
“He’s in a safe place.”
Also, later on when he promises Eric that
if he follows the rules, he’ll see his son
again, he darts his eyes down towards where
the safe is.
"If you agree to that then you will see your son again."
These clues given audibly by Jigsaw aren’t
the only hints that what the police are seeing
on the screens isn’t taking place in real
time.
If we look at some more of the background
details of the workshop, we can find even
more evidence.
When police discover the numbers counting
down next to the monitors, they assume it’s
a bomb, and later decide that it’s probably
a countdown to the end of the Nerve Gas game.
However, if you do the math, which normally
I don’t like to do but will make an exception
for you, the viewers, the timer has over 4
hours to go, whereas the game was only supposed
to last 2-3 hours.
"Three hours from now the door to this house will open.
Unfortunately you only have two hours to live."
There are also a few items that are seen in
both the Nerve Gas House and The Wilson Steel
Plant.
Items don’t typically exist in two places
at once.
What I’m getting at is the events taking
place on the computer screens cannot be taking
place at the same time as the police raid.
The wheelchair with the mannequin upon which
the note for Obi is found can be seen in the
room with the monitors.
The tricycle that Billy the Puppet used to
greet the police when they first arrived at
the steel plant is also present in the hallway
over at the house and the X Marks the Spot
painting can be seen hanging in the background
in Jigsaw’s workshop.
Earlier I mentioned briefly how Jigsaw developed
a God-complex, and this painting has a very
biblical look to it, like something you might
find in a church.
He probably does consider his workshops to
be his churches, going so far as to light
candles to perform a ceremony on Amanda in
Saw 3.
The signal that the Metropolitan Police’s
Tech Team leads them back to a different house,
where Rigg hits pause on the VCR to determine
that the game they had been watching on the
screens all along was already over.
One question you might have had is where Jigsaw
is getting all of these empty houses and buildings.
Fans of the franchise know that John Kramer
was once involved in a project called Urban
Renewal Group which helped provide housing
to low-income families, but he abandoned the
endeavor halfway through.
I think that the Nerve Gas House was going
to be one of these homes, but John reinforced
it to make it the setting of his game.
The fake out house was probably a replica
or model home, which would explain why it
has the same layout and why Jigsaw was able
to trick the SWAT team.
The twist in this movie works great because
as the audience, we are on the same level
as the protagonists: the police.
We are being presented the events out of order,
because that’s how they are perceiving the
situation.
We find out the truth when they find out.
Whereas, in a movie like Jigsaw, the story
is told the way that it is just to trick the
audience, there’s no other practical reason
for doing it that way and it feels artificial.
Another thing that Saw II gets right that
you may not have thought about is the theming
of the traps to fit the character who is playing
them.
For example, it seems the Needle Pit Room
was once a nursery.
We see ABCs written on the walls, baby bottles,
toys, carriages and even creepy little infant
mannequins.
Xavier is revealed to have been a drug dealer
who took advantage of his clients’ addictions.
When a junkie becomes addicted, their bodies
become dependent on the drugs.
Just as a baby in a nursery needs it’s parents to provide
for it, the drug addicts need to keep crawling
back to Xavier to get their fix.
Desperation seems to be a key theme in the
film.
Had Obi not been so desperate to get both
antidotes, he could have seen the nozzle to
turn off the flames of the Furnace Trap with
minimal burn damage.
Had Addison not been in such a huge rush to obtain
the antidote in the Razor Box, she might have
noticed that it was already unlocked, which
would allow her to open it up and get what
she needs without putting her wrists in harm’s
way.
And had everyone just taken a moment to sit
down and think about the clues given by Jigsaw…
"The numbers are in the back of your mind.
The clue to their order can be found over
the rainbow.”
...they could have figured out that each of
them had numbers written on the back of their
heads, each one with a different color of
the rainbow.
By arranging them in the order of Roy G Biv,
(Red, Orange, Yellow, Green, Blue, Indigo
and Violet, they would have obtained the combination
to the safe.
The big one of course, is Eric Matthews, whose
desperation to find his son led him back to
the ways of police “brutality”.
All he had to do to get his son back was sit
there and talk with Jigsaw.
When the contestants of the game discover
the X, they find the photo proving that Daniel
Matthews is Eric Matthews son.
In the photo, they’re at a New York Knicks
game.
While the location of the Saw movies is in
an unnamed fictional city only ever nicknamed
The Fairweather State, there are a lot of
clues like this that it’s supposed to be
somewhere in the Northeastern United States,
like the license plates being similar to New
Jersey and the New York skyline in the
Spiral trailer.
"Enjoy it while it lasts."
At about 73 minutes into Saw 2 there’s this
3 minute stretch where there's just a whole bunch of
horror references for some reason.
It starts when the tech team discovers the
location of the fake out house, which is at
237 North Hyde Crescent.
Two three seven is an homage to the spookiest
number in all of horror: Room 237 from The
Shining.
If you aren’t a big fan of The Shining,
you might think this is just a coincidence, but trust
me when I say it’s not, if you pay attention
you’ll notice this number come up over and
over in all kinds of horror films.
The way Hyde is spelled makes me think it
could be a nod to the classic novel Dr. Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde.
Then there’s another potential street name
homage.
“Make a right on Alfred.”
It’s a bit unusual to see a first name used
as a street name like that, and the murder
mystery house nature of Saw 2 leads me to
believe this was a reference to, perhaps the
most iconic horror director of all time: Alfred
Hitchcock.
Another iconic horror director was Wes Craven,
and his 1972 film, Last House on the Left
would also be mentioned on this car ride.
“Last house on the left.”
After this, we see the conclusion of the Nerve
Gas House game.
“Come on. Let me in!
Let me in!”
“Let me in!”
As I mentioned in the last episode, one of
the staples of the Saw franchise is that there’s
always a character who plays dead in order
to get an upper hand.
In this case is Daniel who plays dead to get
the jump on Xavier.
I can’t show that, because it’s too gory
for YouTube, but look, someone finally flushed
the toilet.
And that’s one of the last things I’d
like to compliment Saw 2 on.
It decided which aspects of the first movie
would become staples of the series, and set
the tone that would be used for the next 5
installments.
It goes back to what I was saying earlier
about this really being Darren Lynn Bousman’s
franchise.
He departed after Saw 4, but handed the torch
to the production designer that he brought on for
his Saw movies: David Hackl, and David would
hand it off to the series’ editor Kevin
Gruetert to finish it out.
So the team was all together as early as Saw
2, part of the reason that the tone is consistent.
Saw 2 would establish Bousman as a director,
but the biggest box-office success in the
franchise would be his next endeavor: Saw
3.
So make sure you join me on the next episode
of Things You Missed by subscribing to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ringing that deathbell
for notifications and I will see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.